وهتتواصل الجهود الانسانيه
لمؤازره المنكوبين اعلنت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه عن انطلاق الجسر الجوي لاغاثه
متضرري الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا وسنعرض
على حضراتكم هذه الصور التي تاتينا من ارض
مطار الملك خالد الدوليه بالرياض حيث
تستعد اليات ومعدات من فرق الدفاع المدني
السعودي لشحنها عبر طائره خاصه استعدادا
لانطلاقها الليله الى مطار اضنه التركي
ضمن حمله المساعدات التي امر بها العاهل
السعودي الملك سلمان وولي عهده الامير
محمد بن سلمان
العمل الانساني السعودي هو عمل انساني بحث
غير مرتبط باي اي جده سياسيه دينيه عرقيه
ولذلك الفرق التي ذهبت توجيه التي لديها
العمل لرفع او لمساعده المحتاجين من هذا
الزلزال دون النظر للموقع او المكان او اي
دوافع اخرى بالنسبه لما يصدر من جهات او
دول او منظمات
لا ننظر اليه نحن نعمل كما كنا نعمل في
السابق مع عدد كبير من المنظمات الامميه
والدوليه وكذلك
المنظمات الغير ربحيه في سوريا الموثوقه
نعمل معهم
وبدانا بالفعل منذ ان صدر التوجيه الكريم
بالتواصل معهم ولنا موثوقيه عاليه في هذه
المنظمات التي نعمل معها ولدينا اليات
رقابه لضمان ان العمل الانساني السعودي
يصل للمحتاجين